a lot of people ask me what's going to
happen if the market crashes well
firstly I don't think it's going to I
mean I'm not saying it's not going to
dip I'm not saying that properties are
going to always go up and up and up and
never go down but I don't think that but
the property prices could possibly crash
crash and keep crashing and that is just
because we're living you know small
island and there's a shortage of houses
and an overpopulation of people so I
don't think it can happen but here's the
really important thing here's the really
really born thing people just say what
happens if the market crashes they're
actually talking nonsense because even
if the even if house prices crashed what
usually happens when property prices go
low is and there's economic crisis is
everybody has to rent so if everyone has
to rent them rents go up if you own a
house as long as you don't plan on
having to sell it if you just buy it and
you're planning on renting out if my
property portfolio shrunk in value by
50%
would it actually affect me on a
day-to-day basis and the answer is none
because my rent is gonna continue coming
in the same so unless you're planning on
buying to sell it doesn't matter if the
market crashes but ultimately it won't
that's kind of my thoughts on the whole
thing I'd love to know what you think
please put your comments below do you
think the markets going to crash if it
did crash would it affect you and my bet
is if you're a professional property
investor and if you own properties my
bet is that if the market did crash it
wouldn't affect you at all because you
still get your rents so maybe they
thought I'll see you next time thank you
so much for watching this video it's
mentoring on a Monday every single week
at 7 p.m. on a Monday between 8 p.m. I'm
gonna be live answering all your
comments and questions don't forget to
subscribe right over here so you'll
never miss one of these videos I'll see
you next week at 7 p.m.
also if you haven't got a copy of my
book you need this in your life you can
get it from Amazon for ten-pound 99 or a
gift from me absolutely free down below
in the description link I'll see you
next week Monday at 7 p.m.